my name is William Lee I'm a PhD student
in computer science at MIT and for this
course I was a graduate instructor for
6811 principles and practice of
assistive technology and that meant I
was one of the co instructors of the
class and my name is Grace toe I'm a
lecturer for six dot 811 and basically
our class is about pairing students up
with clients with disabilities to create
a customized piece of assistive
technology for them over the course of a
semester so the reason why I got into
teaching this course is partly because
of William because William invited me
I'm but also the background to that was
that over the summer at MIT I had
founded a very similar class called open
style lab where we teamed up students
with clients with disabilities as well
except that in that case we were asking
the students to create clothing for them
so this entire area of designing around
the constraints of disability is very
interesting to me because first of all
days very immediate community impact I
think because of that too then the
students have a lot of motivation to try
their best to learn because they see
that you're really impacting a real
person and helping to solve a real
problem instead of just doing you no
problem sets or solving kind of abstract
challenges I'm and I think to be honest
that one of the things I love is seeing
the students get comfortable talking to
talking to and talking about people with
disabilities over time as well because I
think very often in society it is a huge
amount of discomfort surrounding
disability in it's not that people don't
care it's just that they don't want to
say the wrong things you don't want to
be offensive and so equipping our
students if that skills to be able to
engage the community is really important
so I was a fortunate as an undergrad to
work at a children's rehabilitation
hospital one summer and learn about the
space of assistive technology and I
ended up doing that in my undergraduate
thesis and so when I went to grad school
I wanted to continue working in
assistive technology and I was fortunate
to be able to do that here at MIT so my
master's thesis was working a lot in
speech recognition for people with
different speech challenges with
multiple sclerosis that maybe affects
their speech so I think it's a really
similar to grace I think it's a really
fascinating area to work in very
personally meaningful but also very
interesting design constraints and
challenges in working in this space and
so with respect to the class my master's
thesis advisor Seth teller started this
class back in 2011 I was fortunate to be
the first teaching assistant in the
class and then to get involved in it
with a with a big team including grades
for sure over the past over the past
semester